[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Michel el midoro
bonsoir bonsoir On commence ces
informations avec la tempête carariane
qui est attendue dans les ivelines tout
à fait Mathilde arrivée du car
nord-ouest du pays la tempête karane va
commencer à souffler dès ce soir sur
notre département des vents environ 40
km/h sont attendus mais c'est surtout
pour la T que des bourrasques à 80 à kmh
se feront ressentir dans la soirée pour
le jeudi ce sera très avec des rafales à
près de 90 km/h le reste de la semaine
des pointes à 70 km/h sont attendu face
au risque de chute d'arbres plusieurs
communes du département ont décidé de
fermer leur parc pendant ces journées
mouvementées prenez donc garde en
sortant de chez vous ce n'est qu'à
partir du lundi 6 novembre que
l'intensité devrait diminuer
progressivement demain c'est le début du
mois de novembre un mois important pour
ceux qui essayent d'arrêter de fumer dès
demain démarre la 8e édition du mois
sans tabac un défi collectif national
sur 30 jours pour en finir avec cette
mauvaise habitude aujourd'hui c'est le
dernier jour pour s'inscrire
gratuitement sur le site internet de
l'opération si vous décidez d'y
participer vous recevrez un kit d'arrêt
du tabac une consultation avec un
professionnel et l'entraide de toute une
communauté grâce aux réseaux sociaux
rappelons qu'arrêter de fumer pendant un
mois multiplie par 5 les chances de
cesser définitivement une bonne occasion
de rejoindre les 115000 participants
déjà inscrits on poursuit ces
informations avec une tribune qui a été
signée par 61 députés Renaissance dont
l'une est vinoise ces personnalités
politiques de la majorité présidentielle
appelle à la protection des populations
civiles victimes du conflit Israël au
palestinien dans le quotidien l'opinion
parmi les signataires la député de la 7e
circonscription desésivblin nadiae qui
appelle à une trêve humanitaire à Gaza
dans leur tribune les députés écrivent
je cite une vie palestinienne vaut une
vie française qui vaut une vie
israélienne ce texte intervient après
l'extension des opérations militaires
dans la région on va désormais parler de
football hier soir se ten la 67e
cérémonie du Ballon d'Or au théâre du
châtelé à Paris et Kyan Mbappé a terminé
sur le podium et bien que le joueur des
Bleus n'est pas reçu la prestigieuse
distinction il a tout de même terminé à
la 3e place devant lui Lionel Messi
earling hand sur sa page Instagram il a
tenu à féliciter le joueur argentin pour
son titre pour Rael attaquant de 24 ans
du pariss-germain a été formé à
l'Institut national du football de
clirefontaine dans les ivelines le
buteur devra patienter au minimum jus
l'année prochaine pour espérer décrocher
le Graal et bien merci beaucoup
michelmidoro pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78 news